[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention à la marche 2/3 top mais n'est
pas possible alors il est pas mauvais 1
al
moundir ne lâche pas frérot tout est
dans la tête j'allais venir s'il te
plaît ne lâche pas tout est dans la mire
on ne dira jamais battu gilles verdez
mais j'ai fait exprès tout ça ça c'est
voilà un petit peu car j'ai amené watch
en pions ça va il va défier art c'est un
immense champion
c'est un garçon que j'adore c'est
vraiment un de mes amis il est avec nous
ce soir
il est champion olympique et lui il veut
défier mounir vaut au poids de ninon 4
je sens qu'on peut rester jusqu'à 21h30
un comme ça
[Musique]
moundir pense à denis brogniart
c'est dans la tête vous de lire
moi j'ai mon pote l'aï je peux johnny
c'est que celui-là je ne lâcherai jamais
eu lieu bravo vous me dire je rappelle
que vous dire hé ben a gagné contre la
terreur gilles verdez pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent
vous ne vous dire ça fait une minute les
gars me l'a uni de vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au niveau pas assez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
remarquez quand même que tu fais jamais
les épreuves subies mais quelquefois au
début je n'ai pas pensé
[Applaudissements]
mais rené sur le mode je fasse le poids
contre camille combal
ouais ouais bon là ça va durer beaucoup
moins lourd attention c'est parti
3 2 1 tin tin tin tin tin
face à commander son très longtemps
vraiment
il faut
assez pour tonio garde
marché couvert
c'est bon
americana la deuxième et faisait la
manche verges et c'est bon là le jour à
ton portable hashmat camille et camille
davantage ses parents
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]